oh we're going to die I'll be back
[Music]
hey how's it going who are you doing in
here okay alright anyway so look around
the van do you see anything suspicious
here something that might be missing
untapped potential yeah so when I look
around this van I don't see failed plans
like Oh doesn't have enough power for a
fridge nope
I see more opportunity than we ever let
on before it no right bubble with my
whiteboard thank you thank you thank you
just give it a good smell
I mean look over the smell of the
rotting pumpkins and the the Wawa cuz
unthinking um haunted house oh yeah
that's right what do you see stores like
this they're basically pop-up shops
pop-up shops are all the rage there's
tons of clothing stores that are just
pop-up shops and they come and go and
then they're gone people love it because
they love the rarity of it
so we dress this place up to the T we
already got the jacket Landers we
already got the broken TV we already got
the non-existent fridge we already got
the terrifying people over here and then
we can have the most successful Harmon
has a mental Los Angeles how about that
all right let's get to work so what do I
have
I've got scary lights power doodly-doo
oh yeah don't help me or anything
stuff up we've also got wall decorations
for all the blood we've got various
slogans such as keep out we should be
ridiculous cuz they're already in Zoe's
like shouldn't walked in here let me see
if I can slap this bad boy oh nice so
deadly
possible costume I've got you a goon got
you
sexy Chucky which would you rather have
got an inflatable Skellington white man
once told me if you had one shot one
opportunity would you take it or would
you blow Oh des is scary man squeeze
real good right in the you gotta grab a
button alright you gotta give a little
good
well he's dying clear that might be the
scariest thing I've ever seen
nice sorcery spots I need more room to
flow
[Music]
yeah come with me
we need to let people know on the
outside this is vans real deal so just
add on with the sticker legacy of this
van I think it's only appropriate thanks
for getting here in there
[Music]
possibly the scariest thing I've ever
seen Stanley you'll believe me when I
say hi I'm Stanley I'm gonna murder you
now shut that door and let's get the
killer sure buddy ah ah joke's on you Oh
spooky we'll just set that right right
by to keep out like just old luminate so
people know you know safety regulations
say that you need to like to let people
know about your their imminent death and
mistake oh crap oh listen to the sign
this very clearly there for your
protection
okay so we got Stanley you got the keep
out we got the strobe we got your
werewolf hands we've got a lot of murder
weapons we'll clean this up later
yeah disembodied hand you should totally
do it Rick we would you know like that
but better than I did
oh we got spooky skulls and glow sticks
mold busters that went inside
sound cool sound fun let's get to
spooking speed
we're not open yet boo eek no no you
don't see it we're not open it uh take
chica for a walk take a potty we got it
hang out we're not ready yet okay pull
up there no I'm fine it's it's a startup
we need a little more time it's better
to be late and good then early and not
good cuz then people there we go then
get out we were ill-prepared for this
launch day is so scary we'll get in and
help this spider web you forget the
spider women idiot we crack open one of
these bad boys yellow is the scariest
color Adriana got a duck underneath the
yellow oh you have a screwdriver
make a friend she had a good poop
I watched you do that nice still kept
looking it's not even I I fixed it by
breaking it pretty spooky right don't
get too scared get a good shot of his
reaction enjoy your stay
good luck oh Jesus
[Laughter]
smells very piney in here
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice nice and bouncy
it's earthquake zone here in the haunted
van wonder whose foot is this oh my gosh
scary dude nice pumpkins what is the
smell is this smell it's like pine tar
pine glue lemons smell is lemons fun yo
what you thought if you have to give a
review I mean one star cuz you can't
really move but I'd give it to for the
shaky all right so we found a park we've
got everything ready to go
Tyler's gonna get in costume soon but
I'm gonna send out a tweet here come see
the world's first pop-up haunted house
look for the van in Palms Park on
Overland Avenue and bingo Bongo it's
there to go we'll do it like drug-dealer
style we'll just get the first few
people in for free get him hooked on the
experience and it'll keep coming back
for more right there's no way we can
lose here's how it's gonna be
you are gonna be inside and you're gonna
be the second scare you're gonna you're
gonna like mislead them they're gonna
come in through the passenger door
you're gonna be here post it up and
you're gonna be like I'm scary I'm scary
just when they least suspect it tiles
gonna pop up in the driver's side window
just boo and really get on the first
spook joerger then gonna move backwards
into your spot in the corner and film
their reaction so we can really see it
in good glorious HD and then at the end
once they have their fill they'll come
out this way Bob's your uncle
they'll be done meanwhile after I get
him in I'll shake
and sound good okay we got a plan you
look very spooky take that off before
someone calls the cops
we got a paying customer here by the way
this cost money I hope you brought your
wallet
I mean the bandhas well then I can say
for my time is up I hope you had a
satisfying terrifying experience why I
still we understand customer are you
ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you make it out alive generated one
out of like ten maybe either like a two
and a half of the growth both both sides
in spectrum that doesn't make any sense
this is what death looks like isn't it
[Music]
have you been doing me no well alright
then you're up next
going pretty well so far I'd say I'd say
our average score is probably around
shut up shut up you probably around a
6.5 maybe a 6.7 which i think is pretty
good for a mobile pop-up haunted house
like about the best we could hope for
you'll never ever escape
if you gotta Ranger that one out of ten
oh that's our bad oh we're going to die
if you had a rate of 1 out of 10 that
brings the average way up yeah
you found the mini-fridge Jesse we did
yeah there's someone named Ileana that
was real nice about this and actually
gave yo do you want to sign the the van
yeah all right so we're finally done
with that not bad for a first day in a
haunted house I'd say if I learned
anything from the experience maybe don't
make a creepy white van creepier by
parking it in the middle of the woods
and putting a hothouse but nonetheless
it was a good experience and it was a
lot of fun everybody that came by was
super sweet everybody that we met was
just awesome
and I love doing these things I
especially love doing these things with
you so thanks for being here for me and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye-bye